and welcome to hannity it is the night
before the all-important pennsylvania
primary and coming up the candidate and
that i and president trump endorse for
the senate dr mehmet oz will be here
plus we will continue our investigation
into his opponent kathy barnett who is
backed by the shadowy swampy never
trumper group named club for grove i
know they used to be republican they're
not anymore now tonight the mysteries
surrounding kathy barnett gets stranger
and stranger there are still more
questions than there are answers tonight
about barnett's background her rhetoric
political beliefs her tweets that are
beyond controversial whether or not she
can even compete in a general election
that's straight ahead but first we turn
to the horrific shooting in buffalo new
york over the weekend a deranged racist
monster opened fire at a supermarket
murdering 10 innocent americans
tonight we all do pray for all of the
victims and their families and the
entire city of buffalo everyone impacted
by this despicable act of violence sadly
yet unfortunately predictably many on
the left almost immediately started
exploiting their pain their suffering
for political gain in fact after the
shooting it took democrats just three
hours to start blaming republicans and
conservatives and talk show hosts and
fox news of course it's the same
terrible smear tactic that liberals have
been using for years now in the 90s you
might remember former president bill
clinton tried to blame rush limbaugh and
talk radio for the oklahoma city bombing
he let us he later said quote so the
instrument carrying this forward was
basically the right wing radio talk show
hosts and they understand clearly that
emotion was more powerful than reason
most of the time
now you might remember in 2007 then
senator joe biden remember he blamed
george w bush newt gingrich for the
virginia tech massacre you might
remember in 2016 the new york times
blaming the entire republican party for
the pulse nightclub shooting in 2019
democrats blaming president trump for
the el paso shooting and just today
democrat eric swalwell blaming house
republicans for a shooting in california
where apparently a chinese man opened
fire on a taiwanese congregation swalwow
referred to the shooter as the gop's
quote boy whatever that means now we can
go on and on democrats always play the
blame game unless of course it does not
benefit them politically
almost no one in the media mob is
covering the 33 people that were shot in
chicago there are their names right
there over the weekend did you hear
their names did you hear any reports did
you hear any outrage did you hear any
blame as per usual this program we've
done this since 2009 we scrolled the
names of thousands and thousands of
names of people shot in chicago that
you've never heard about and you might
ask well why is that why every weekend
30 40 50 60 people shot we never hear
about those people shot well democrats
can't blame republicans they can't blame
conservatives and they'd have to look at
their policies of let's see relax on
crime uh defund dismantle and no bail
laws so not a peep from the democrats
about the 10 people shot in baltimore
during a single day did any of you hear
about the 34 people shot during one week
in los angeles does joe biden ever talk
about the daily violence gripping
america's cities because the democratic
party policies defund dismantle nobel
now tomorrow biden will pay a visit to
buffalo frankly rightly so but keep in
mind he didn't visit wisconsin last fall
after daryl brooks murdered six and
injured 62 during an attack on a
christmas parade he didn't visit new
york in april after a black nationalist
named frank james opened fire in a new
york city subway shooting 10. in fact
democrats didn't play the blame game
after either of these attacks by the way
never mind the 574 riots that let's see
killed dozens of americans injured
thousands of cops caused billions of
property damage their silence was
deafening they called those protests
mostly peaceful they weren't even close
to mostly peaceful in 2017 after a
far-left bernie sanders superfan and
according to the daily caller rachel
maddow-lover attempted to massacre
republican lawmakers at a congressional
baseball practice that's the one where
steve scalise nearly lost his life and
no blame game there either this was a
politically motivated act of violence
from a guy who openly declared his love
for bernie sanders and rachel maddow but
following the shooting democrats didn't
smear maddow they didn't sh
they didn't go after bernie sanders and
nor should they have no one should be
held accountable for the evil actions of
a depraved individual whatever their
political leanings may or may not be
everyone's responsible for their own
conduct in fact right here on this
program uh when these incidents came up
and they turned out to be big supporters
of liberals i have been saying it for
years take a look
let me make one thing clear we believe
that every individual they are
responsible for their own actions and
their own decisions i did not blame
bernie sanders on this program i went
out of my way not to blame him for the
fact that one of his supporters was
violent against those ball those people
playing on the ball field
now earlier i said the same thing about
al gore remember the unabomber radically
far left environmentally conscious
terrorist who is apparently an avid
reader of al gore's book earth and the
balance for the unbalanced but i didn't
blame al gore for the psychotic actions
of ted kaczynski either we've been
remarkably consistent we condem all
riots we condem all violence and we
don't blame people that did not cause
people to act this way take a look
i thought we were always taught by the
left never blame the victim for example
you had the unabomber in his hut the al
gore's book earth and the balance was in
there did al gore inspire the una bomber
that wouldn't be fair or you could take
any number of examples where
left-wing
words do not cause people you cannot say
that words are causing people to be
violent but that's the narrative
on this show we condemn all violence we
deplore all acts of hatred all acts of
bigotry
we stand up against racism where we see
it we refuse to exploit horrific loss of
life or political gain democrats
liberals the media mobs should be
ashamed of themselves but sadly they
have no shame they will do anything for
power they'll do anything to lie smear
besmirch and slander conservatives and
by the way for the record no one spews
more violent rhetoric than the left in
case you need a refresher course here
you go
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to
destroy
what you stand for what you care about
but i like to debate this gentleman and
i said no i said if we were in high
school i'd take him behind the gym and
beat the hell out of him you got to be
ready to take a punch
you got to be ready to throw a punch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone should take note of that on
both levels that this isn't they're not
going to let up and they should not i
want to tell you gorsuch i want to tell
you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
get up in the face of some congress
people it does you any good running away
from donald trump i think you need to go
back and
punch him in the face how dare he say
the things he does of course i want to
punch him in the face
yes
i have thought an awful lot
about blowing up the white house
when was the last time an actor
assassinated a president
but michelle says that you know when
they go low we go high
no
they go low we kick them
they go low we kick him imagine just for
a second that was rhetoric coming from
conservatives or donald trump supporters
or this news channel what would the
reaction in the country be hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else